Các bạn khi tưởng dự báo trong chiều này 1 năm tâm mấy,
cú vực lo mắt mộ được dự báo có mươi bởi lượng mới phục viến từ 2 mời đến 4 mời miếng
của buộ có nước trên bởi miếng miếng miếng miếng
Mời lượng làm ra tăng ngự cơ gờ gập ong tại cá không chung thấp lồ thị của con nghiệp
Lông thời tiê bàn mùi ke luo quách sẽ lợn tất ở cú vực biền nuy
Rồi người nướng của hành lưu báo dù mô đặc buổi bài klong vií đã có doa mạnh keb chiến dật kem mi một
Cô tốt quan lên có gió mạnh cấp tắm, giật cấp dời, sống miệng cao 2 mì hay lòng nét,
cửa ông quan lên có gió mạnh cấp tắm, giật cấp chiến,
món cái khoảng lình có gió mạnh cấp chiến, giật cấp mi hai,
khoảng hà còn lên có gió mạnh cấp tắm, giật cấp chiến,
giữ báo đến 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 1, 1 năm tâm mì,
báo xuống một suy yếu thành áp thích nhật đối,
sau đó là một vùng áp thấp chiến của bật biến Nam tình, khoảng tay chúng quốc,
chúng đâm giữ báo khi tưởng thị văn cuân ra cho biết,
giữ báo đám đồ vộ và đến điện xúc quốc,
y cơ thiên tay cho hành lữ báo vẫn còn nấm cáo,
trên biển khu vực chữ tắc đậu của bác vị mắt bộ,
báo gồm đặc của bài cao vị, văn đồn của tốt,
khu vực này có có gió mạnh cấp sấu, giật cấp mì cấp tắm,
sống biển cao từ 2 đến 3 mẹt biển đậu.
Được kiện thời tiên, người dì em có thể gây lần,
chiêm hoặc hồng tâu cá, tâu vận tay, tâu dú liệt và cấp phương tiện hoàn động trên biển.
Lông bán rối trồng thị sản, cu vực nèo đầu tâu thiên và cung xin văn biển có quyết cơ hữ hồng,
hóa đầu khai tháp thị sản, vận tay và giúp lịch trên biển có khả năng bị gián gọi.
Đối với khu vực rất liền văn biển, cu vực rất liền và văn biển
biển phía mắt tình còn liền có gió mạnh cấp nâm, có lúc cấp sấu,
dịch cấp mì, gió mạnh có thể làm tốt mấy nhà,
gió hồng cung xin tạm, gái độ kây xanh biển còn cáo,
anh hưởng đến hệ thống điện, tâu pin liên làc và rau thông.